[Music]
i am
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
imagine if a baby fell out the sky and
fell into your arms what would you be
thinking
[Music]
open the bag for me miss
[ __ ]
imagine a woman never wanted a child in
her mid-30s searching for something in
her life but it isn't a baby i wanted
the audience's first impression to
really be what mine was like wow
and that it's a comedy horror you know i
just love the combination of genres can
i leave this with you
we came up with the show when we were
traveling a couple of years ago the idea
kind of fell out of the sky it just felt
like a kind of wacky comedy horror
premise and then as the story evolved
and through the development process we
kind of realized that actually it was
becoming more and more about the kind of
deep ambivalence that we both were
feeling about
whether we would become parents i think
i've forgotten how normal people behave
i guess like one of the big themes is
kind of love and the way we're kind of
told we should love each other and the
ways like we actually do
main themes sisterhood just sort of
family and community and mothering and
motherhood
the show is centered around three women
natasha her sister bobby and mrs eves
bobby's a real people-pleaser she's a
real bubbly person
nut
mrs eves i think she's very unique there
is so much courage in the way the story
is written and the way we're telling it
i think it's a real like
compassionate funny scary dark
enlightening look at motherhood
you had a baby
but you don't you don't want a baby
it's light and it's fun sometimes and
equally scary and dark it just has like
so much
versatility
it's a totally
original show
come be ready to laugh and be a bit
frightened connect some of the
characters and connect some of the
stories
and hopefully have a bit to think about
in terms of mothering and motherhood
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you